so yes tonight we'll be talking about
creating squares for your pieces which
as I was saying it can be a pretty
difficult subject if you've never
thought about it before sometimes
there's a nice closed position
things are very static nothing is really
going to change much as far as the pawn
structure is concerned and sometimes
there's just an easy square you can say
oh that's the ideal square like if I
could put my piece there that'd be great
I would just put it there
and it's real easy sometimes that square
doesn't exist
but there's a square you could create on
the board that you could eventually use
to create a hole or some sort of ideal
square where you could place a piece so
today we're going to sort of focus on
using the pawns a lot of creating
squares is going to have to do with the
pawn structures and pawn moves and the
pawns really are indicative in chess of
where you want to put your pieces so by
using the pawns to create weaknesses in
your opponent's territory you can create
ideal squares for your pieces so we're
going to go ahead and throw it now over
to the board and this first game this
first little puzzle that we're going to
look at tonight this is the game between
Viktor Lesnick ax and lugar Gashi mauve
so 227 hundreds very good strong players
and hopefully this will be the easy
puzzle of the night so we can get an
idea of what it means and if you're just
joining us we're creating squares for
our pieces so so let the audience think
about this position for a minute and at
home you may want to pause because I'll
stop talking and they'll think for
several minutes so if you want the same
amount of time you should pause your
video and try to solve this for yourself
and okay and I thought this was like the
easy one but I showed it to two of our
instructors or our higher rated
instructors here and one of them
actually really struggled here and the
other one found it in one second so this
is probably either really easy or really
hard for you but yeah uh I'll sit here
quietly for a minute
guys just a chance to look at the
position and think about what you would
play here as white f4 okay and what's
your idea are you just creating you're
just putting your knight here are you
thinking of some sort of like sacrifice
to get a knight here
what using you have the sacrificial idea
and I think okay f4 it's actually just a
normal perfectly fine move and that's
also sort of the problem with these
strategical puzzles is there's not just
one right move in any of the examples
you're going to see tonight f4 is
definitely a very reasonable move that a
white really should consider seriously
and I assume they did it's not what was
played in the game but that doesn't mean
it's it's wrong or inaccurate or
anything like that so f4 definitely is
the right idea and you know because it's
not a tactics puzzle where there's only
one right answer and everything's an
only move which is sort of the problem
with these these puzzles in general but
I think the idea that was played in the
game is a little more accurate and a
little more instructive so but yeah
Ford's definitely on the agenda
a4 is the right answer so you're
immediately putting pressure on the veep
on which is going to force black to make
some concession he doesn't really want
to take and let you get pressure along
the a file so it's almost certain that
you'll push b4 and this gives away a
very key square here the c-4 square
which would be ideal for one of our
pieces especially at night because if
one of our Knights landed on c4 you'd
have some pressure on d6 so what did
white play in this position your Knights
attacked so so hopefully you don't play
Knight c4 nd - okay
yeah so that's the interesting question
so the class is wandering 92 or 91 why
would you go to d1 yeah and this last
wall was played in the game night went
to d1 to e3 and then from there you can
go to c4 and you'll have two nights that
can use that square and this is enough
to say that you you've solved the puzzle
if you solve this much so we'll go
through the game then I went to d1 black
played a5 to combat this idea he's going
to put a bishop here so that okay you're
fighting for the c-4 square the night
went to e3 and we got our Knight to c4
so this is the example if you saw this
much then you got the puzzle correct in
the game we'll just show one thing in
this position white didn't have to play
the way they played we'll just show the
next move though white played here which
sacrifices the exchange on f1 so black
took it you know it's looking pretty
good revealed attack on your knight but
white had this idea in mind and white
has lots of compensation for the you
know the slight material deficit you got
a past a pawn you got a lot of light
squares on the Queen side that you can
use and white did end up going on to win
this game so okay very good
and so that was hopefully the the easy
one we'll look at some slightly more
compote
we'll get some slightly more complicated
examples here which one first this will
do this one so this is the game between
let's see at TN back row and Ian Rogers
in Rogers being the Australian
Grandmaster the stun commentary here for
us before a very friendly guy he's
always fun when he comes here but he
would be on the receiving end of a loss
in this position so okay we look at a
few moves just to get an idea of the
plot it was a rapid game as well okay so
in this position what ends up getting
lots of pressure
and so we'll pause here and we'll think
about using our pawns to create squares
for our pieces and white here is is
slightly better you get more space and
you have the potential to really
activate your pieces here but how are
you going to do it so again this one's a
little bit harder and it's more of a
plan it's sort of a long-term idea and
there's more than one way you can
actually go about it so I'll go ahead
and I'll I'll pause again at home you
may want to pause your video for for
additional time but uh okay I'll give
you guys a little bit time to think here
Bishop g4 is a very good move there's
absolutely nothing wrong with it it's
it's the computer second choice and yet
this is just a good way to improve your
piece the knight will probably end up
going to c5 which prevents you from
putting your bishop on a nice square
over here and I mean again there's
there's nothing wrong with this plan
it's just a very good move but it was
not the plan that was chosen in the game
okay so what what's the plan okay a3 if
they play c5 you play b4 anyway okay do
you see how you're going to get a ideal
square for one of your pieces yeah the
rook is going to end up going over this
way
somewhere like over here like a seven
it's going to use the hey file and it's
going to go to a seven yeah so we're
getting close and it will give one hint
it doesn't actually have to do with with
the rook the rook is at the moment at
least you know doing a pretty good job
keeping this night stuck defending that
that pawn in kind of a silly fashion and
the bishop yeah the bishop does have
this potential in the future to go over
here to g4 which is very good and the
only piece we know we really need to
worry about a little bit is is this guy
it's okay I guess but white found a way
here to really incorporate his a knight
and so by using his his worse place
piece and finding a way to bring it to a
really really optimal square that in
this current position doesn't exist it
needs to be created he was able to get a
very dominating position that that led
to a victory so we're getting very close
nine a four okay and where are you
headed
okay so you're preventing 95 then a 3 B
4 okay but why did you need to put your
night on a 4 to to play this move
because if a 3 immediately you're not
worried about this move are you because
you just played B 4 so yeah a 3 B 4 is
definitely a huge part of this but I
don't think you need to use night a 4 I
think you can find a better Square for
that night all right if you could
liquidate several of the pawns on the
Queen side I guess where do you where
would you ultimately just love for this
night to be d5
yeah d5 is okay that's a fantastic
square right in the center
you know that's immediately it would be
a fork but even if it isn't a fork it's
it does put tremendous pressure on black
unfortunately you can't go there
immediately but but hopefully with all
these clues now we can find the right
plan the right solution and again
there's there's more than one way you
can do it but and that's that's what
happened in the game a3 was played
immediately which is actually slightly
inaccurate well we'll go back but you
have the basic idea is he went over here
so that he's a little bit farther away
he is threatening a check whew
so now white took this is what we were
we're talking about and b4 and the idea
now is b5 and either I take you or you
take me and I get access to the d5
square which is exactly what happened so
you got your check in all right very
good and now he sort of sees what's
coming and in this position we got to a
very ideal square d5 and then white went
on to win this game and not too many
more moves but it is worth noting I mean
it wasn't it was a rapid game to repeat
after the move a three the computer
really wants you to play c5 this would
sort of prevent that idea because even
if you do play b4 we can take once and
we can wait for you to take and if you
end up taking then you bring my knight
here so this actually would have
combated against that idea so it would
have been slightly more accurate to have
begun with taking here first followed up
with a 3 B 4 B 5 ok so very good that
was our second puzzle
we'll move we'll move right along we got
one more loop this one is from blacks
point of view this is the game between
Robert Dabo / anak versus Goran did star
was played in 2000 and will show a few
moves so white has just Castle queenside
and black is as about 300 points higher
rated than his opponent we got sort of
an interesting position where white is
taking control of some of the squares on
the Queen side and we get this very
interesting position and again this this
perhaps is the least satisfying of the
three because there's there's a lot of
solutions that are are decent and
reasonable for black there's there's
several moves that you can play that you
know will dramatically change the
assessment or your chances of winning
but the move that was played I think was
was instructive and very interesting so
again we're trying to create squares for
our pieces and I'll give you guys a
couple minutes here maybe this one's the
hardest who knows because I've shown it
to different people and different people
struggle with different puzzles so okay
I'll just I'll just be quiet for a
minute or two here okay so you're
thinking about taking here
and you might take back with a queen I
agree with that and this is fine it's
perfectly reasonable solution that isn't
what was played and you can follow it up
with a move like Bishop to f6 which is
fully fully reasonable and in no ways
wrong at all you do have to worry about
this move it's not a major issue but
okay you do have to think about what
happens on d5 and okay I mean you can
try to get off the D file in this
position is is fine you might get end up
with a weakness here on e6 but also you
might still also get some pressure here
sometimes so this is possible but I do
like what black did in the game a little
bit better so we'll we'll see and have
we identified perhaps the a possible
ideal square or a possible square that
we might want to get for our pieces is
there any square you wish you could put
a piece but you can't Bishop on f5 it's
going to be hard to be hard to do you
want your guy here you kind of what your
knight on d5 yeah I agree with that just
want the Queen somewhere better okay you
know yeah you want your queen out here
it's
okay you want to put your queen here and
then go I don't know why I did that
which is an interesting idea
mm-hmm yeah I think d5 is the ideal
square you do want to put a knight there
the obvious problem is this pond so b5
yeah okay yeah so this is what was
played in the game um and so you do have
to address this and so obviously there's
there's two ways to take I guess first
I'll look at what what Darian's crazy
suggestion is he just wants to take this
which is a bit extreme but I don't think
it's uh I think you do probably get lots
of compensation if you do end up doing
this so this out this is very possible
will he ever you know will like be able
to just consolidate a little bit
probably bring the Queen back and then
try to I can try to trade nights and
stuff so this is possible also remind
myself what was actually played in the
game so it's in the game b5 and this was
played yeah if you take here c6 is the
the tactical idea in the position yeah
that's the idea
yeah so if Bishop takes it's a big
blunder and yeah you so even if even if
here you know we just put here it's not
that big of a blunder it's a pretty big
blunder
yeah it's mm-hmm but okay we can go here
this also is possible I mean I don't I
don't have to blender it's optional okay
in a position like this black has the
ideas of a five a four with a very
decent position so in the game that's
that's why we can see that this move was
played and also I guess it is also worth
mentioning if you try to be clever
we'll see this this tactical misfire
again you know okay very clever oh so so
that was impossible so so in the game
after b5 he took with the pawn so how
would you guys continue now
95 exactly then yes so this is is enough
so I mean if you take tonight we take
back with a queen and we're attacking
everything so he brought the Queen back
and if you saw this this much it's
enough to say that you you solved the
puzzle we'll look at just a couple more
moves in the game just to see how it
actually went so here which is okay I
guess he took and went over here and now
King be--would is actually a mistake it
wasn't played in the game what would you
guys play on King b1 so we can
understand why black played Queen h4
Queens c4 yeah exactly
so in the game
b3 was played that prevents Queen c4 and
black went up upon and after this move
black would have continued to increase
the advantage had he found this move
attacking the C pawn and okay but okay
in the game by Queen e7 and eventually I
mean there's there was a lot of
weaknesses on this the side of the board
and black went on to win the game but
yeah if you just saw in the initial
position here the idea of trying to get
to the square and here you really had to
work for it and in general that's kind
of how you have to sometimes think in
chess like how can I make this work and
you have to sort of force what you want
to be able to work in the position you
really want to put your knight there but
if you want to do that then you have to
make this move work you know tactically
and strategically and in this position
it does work it doesn't mean like the
game's over but like suddenly wins or
anything that's not how these how these
puzzles work but you know just by
fighting for the squares and getting
control the squares that you want you
can achieve much better position so
hopefully that was a little bit helpful
I wanted to do a shorter one just to
make sure we could get to some games
because people have been sending in
games so we will go over one game that
was submitted I now have received over
100 so you can keep sending them in to a
info at st. Louis chess club org it's a
becoming harder and harder to get your
shown here just because we keep getting
so many I got about 30 in my inbox this
morning so so that's great people keep
sending them in and I'm very happy to to
analyze them so okay this was a game
that was sent in by a gentleman named
Ilyas he says he's a 24 from Greece he
just started playing he played started
playing last summer she started watching
chess videos playing chess on the
Internet
various chess websites he's about 1650
and he's never played a rated game but
he did participate in a simultaneous
exhibition a 40-person Simon with Greek
Grandmaster Johannes Nichol ladies so
here is this is him with the black
pieces against the Grandmaster in the
Simon I would be ultra happy if you
analyzed it in a video in case you find
it interesting and I did I thought it
was a very very good game thank you for
your content you upload on YouTube you
guys are amazing I learned a lot of
stuff keep it up so thank you for all
the kind words and of course you know if
you're for in you write like a paragraph
and somebody did ask you know how do you
choose the things that you choose and
what is funny is a lot of the times I
see a really good game that I want to
analyze but the big mistake people make
is they don't tell me like what color
they are or like you don't have to write
as much as this gentleman did you can
see it's like the whole screen you guys
can't see it but they can see it um you
just kept writing you don't have to
write that much I just kind of need to
know what side you are and you know some
some small details I guess the way I do
is I just randomly click and then once I
find one that's good I'm like right good
so there's no there's no real magic to
it I just you know I just keep goin til
I find a good one and I selected this
one which i think is a great game okay
you got a person that's never played a
rated game he's playing a grandmaster
you might think grandmaster just steam
rolls right over them no big deal but
black fought a very valiant game he did
not win the game but it is very
interesting and instructive so we'll
take a look so the grandmaster played d4
and our protagonist here he played f5
the dutch you know very dynamic and
taken on a grandmaster and you're not
afraid to play some sharp just excellent
Knight f3 which is not you know the main
line it's not a very common move order
but it's it's a very decent way
obviously such a move can't be a mistake
at all so 9 f6 Bishop g5 and part of
whites move order he might be thinking
I haven't done anything with my C pawn
yet maybe I'll put my knight here and
I'll get to play e4 without allowing you
anything so that is indeed what we saw
in the game and there's two options you
can play Bishop e7 which is fine our
hero here he played the most d5 which
enters into the Stonewall formation he's
going to put his his pawns right here
get a nice solid position you don't end
up seeing the Stonewall too much at the
highest level because you are creating
lots of weaknesses but it often is very
solid you know Stonewall it's hard to
break down so we'll see if the
grandmaster is able to do it and
sometimes black does get in attack in
these positions or other times he's just
struggling but solid so we'll see how it
transpires III c6 which isn't the most
common move because perhaps it's not the
most accurate you could have also
developed a bishop first but c6 is going
to be played regardless so we keep going
c4 Bishop d6 which i think is the
correct square for the bishop in this
position and I think the opening you
know very well okay here's got some
normal reasonable position out of the
opening is black i solid I used to play
this a lot but then I was started
playing like I am sand stuff and then I
could never win with black so I gave it
up but here also there's already sort of
an interesting decision I think this is
the first mistake there were a couple
small mistakes by by both sides in this
game I think it's just sort of a
strategical thing that comes from trying
to understand this position so with a
small amount of experience in this line
the main drawback in this position you
put all your your stuff here is the
bishop so the key maneuver in this
position that black almost always tries
to achieve is he wants to do the bishop
wiggle and get the LightSquared bishop
outside of the pawn chain where it can
be traded off for some other piece
so here in the game Queen e8 was played
which isn't like a blunder or anything
but it does put you in the way of the
bishop so that will make it a little bit
more problematic in the future and I
think perhaps Black was thinking about
other lines like the classical Dutch and
other lines where the Queen goes over
here makes a presence over here and is
vital to a King side attack but that's
just not what's going on in this
position in this position really with
this pawn structure you want to get rid
of this piece as soon as possible so
that that also want to find I mean
perhaps this move to is is also a fine
move not a huge fan of this move but uh
okay I mean it doesn't like blow the
game or anything okay and now another
interesting decision that you have to
make he's offering you a trade he's
taking control over a five and I do like
this position and this is sort of the
type of position where even computers
kind of mess up the evaluation because
they can't think long term but I guess
I'll pull the audience here will give
you give you two options you can take or
you can go back to e7 like I said like
to see what the audience would would do
in this position you defend it with a
queen you just go here or something yes
so in general this is the bishop that
you do want to keep on the board so even
though the computer the computer likes
to take but I think this is is a
strategic mistake that the computer just
doesn't understand this is you do want
to keep this guy life and if you ever do
want to have any hopes for an attack
over here very often you know we end up
with these sorts of moves and we get
going over here we do want to keep the
dark-squared bishop on the board so he
went back which i think is correct we
you know it's it's good understanding
which pieces you you want to trade and
which ones you don't this guy we want to
keep on the board because he is
navigating all the dark squares and this
guy is like stuck
so this is the guy we want to get rid of
and this is the guy we want to keep so I
think this was a good decision
okay and now here which is which is fine
h3 and I think here white also had this
this chance to already play a really
bothersome move this would have been
kind of annoying and then black might
have to go back so this move wasn't
wasn't quite right but white did not
exploit it h3 okay a solid move White's
clearly better here and now another
interesting strategical decision a5 and
this this I don't I don't like sometimes
you do end up playing over there but
with this move it sort of makes it seem
like black wants to play on the kingside
you know you're bringing your Queen over
there maybe you're going to try to get
these moves in and bring the Queen over
and do something on the Kings side but
now you're doing something over on the
Queen side and you're trying to do
something on all sides of the board and
we will see this move actually backfire
on our on our protagonist here so okay
95 yes Trading is is fine here
a4 and okay sometimes you do do this and
then but you have your Queen over here
they can sometimes come in and sometimes
you can do stuff on the Queen side but
just with the way you've rearranged your
pieces it's unlikely to succeed in here
white it's sort of an interesting move
a3 just keeping the pond where it is and
well this you know is black really
having any chance of you know exploiting
the weakness over here or is it just
going to be white that gets to go and
pick it up you can also imagine like the
bishop there's a lot of ways of just
going and attacking that pond so it
actually may become a liability more
than it as an asset over there h6 okay
you want to play g5 that's that is the
big point but now Queen d8 which
which is a bit strange probably should
have taken the night because now white
actually has a really decent option of
just jumping into g6 which gives away
two rather overwhelming position but
that was not chosen so I did not
immediately go for that 96 is actually a
he's really bad news for black but night
b1 okay and so we see it and I like goes
here Knight takes the pawn so you got to
do something about it and he found a way
to circumvent this idea 94 right very
good so when the night lands on c3 we
can take it yet weight is still
obviously for choice but you know he's
making making the Grandmaster work you
still have to find a way to make inroads
into the black position here this move
and you know at first when I first saw
this move I'm like oh is there any any
tactics oh nope because it isn't a
protected piece but it's actually a
decent move if as long as there's no no
tactics anywhere this Knight goes we can
take the bishop with check though it is
interesting now you've decided that you
know maybe you do want to trade the dark
squared bishop s' I mean I thought maybe
you would just continue you know going
on somewhere over here and not trading
the bishops we'll see so he just goes
back White's perfectly happy to trade
the funniest would have just been going
back which I think I probably would have
considered and so here he did trade so
you didn't give away your dark squared
Bishop which is your good Bishop and you
still are left with this problem so I
mean will you ever really get the time
to do this now it's you're slowly
running out of time here
and then as funny the next move you went
you went here so you probably wanted to
go there in one move and I don't know at
some point too I probably still want to
like get this out of the way and do the
wiggle
and now you do have to be careful here
which which way should we take back
mm-hmm yeah you definitely don't want to
open the see file so he made the right
decision I mean the rooks are coming in
this would be a big mistake so he took
the correct way no wonder why white took
um you know white definitely doesn't
have to I can keep the tension mm-hmm
yeah yeah I don't yet whites never
really worried about this so yeah you
could just keep the tension and I don't
I know the Grandmaster is like 40 boards
that's a lot
so even white you know made several
mistakes in this game because I don't
think I've ever seen anything that's
that large normally around you I mean
I've seen like 20 boards I moles and
even that's kind of a lot sometimes that
means sometimes there's just five boards
i moles let's you know rather quick so
this is a lot I mean he's I don't know
and I know with Simoes too they start
going around and then people drop out
and they come around faster and faster
and faster so I know the feeling at the
end it gets much harder so the longer
you you last the harder it actually gets
because I get to spend more of their
energy on your board and you get less
and less time so I have no idea what
this situation wasn't in that respect
but uh yeah it is a bit bit strange to
get rid of the tension you kind of like
black yeah I think if you can just solve
this problem that then you're then
things are alright but it's it's not so
easy to do now the bishop goes here
perhaps hinting that it can go here you
know perhaps saying you know you can't
move anywhere I got some pressure here
another move g5 and I think again I
probably would have preferred to move
like this and just get you know my
bishop out I still have dreams of of
wiggling you know but I think yeah I
think I got to do something with this
pretty soon before I run out of time g5
okay very aggressive though
and an interesting move by white I think
it's a good move I it kind of surprised
me at first but uh
g3 which is kind of surprising but I I
assume the point is he wanted to meet
the move at four with taking and then
here so this is his defensive idea you
know he doesn't have to be careful black
still could possibly get an attack in
this position so g3 okay he goes here I
assume the ideas he's going to put his
knight here okay so we're on this guy
and all right so he's sacrificing upon
and he's saying okay you can you can go
take this and then you know I'll go jump
in here I'll get some pressure maybe
I'll be thinking about some sacrifices
okay I dare you to take clip on white
was not interested it's a yeah this idea
looks looks a little bit scary looks a
little bit scary so he blocked the
Queen's diagonal and I mean black is you
know played very well so far I mean I
think so far I should be really happy
with this but he now does make the
decisive mistake that ends up costing
them here so um I assume you should just
go forward in a position like this ask
him he can move his rook here or he can
end up taking I do get some pressure
you'll either play g4 or King g2 or some
move like this and the game will will
continue and black is slowly slowly
solving some of his problems but in the
game a very unfortunate move the knight
went back to d7 an indication that he's
not making a lot of progress here and
now the the strong move f4 just
solidifying the knight on a great square
where really it can never be captured
but black confounded his problems by by
taking the knight in giving way this
huge past pond
and I mean a huge structural advantage
okay but you know it's not over yet
let's let's have a little little bit of
hope here we went to g6 which is
occasionally going to run into g4 due to
the pin but okay are you gonna keep the
bishop here or are you going to take my
pond
what would the Grand Master do kingi -
how inaccurate king h2 and my rook can
use the G file um because white intends
to play g4 so okay the rook will will
use the G file he protected the pawn
which I understand not wanting to lose
the pawn but here g4 would have been a
crusher but white never plays it for
several moves here white should play g4
and would have won really quickly but
but didn't do it and we probably didn't
see the immediate win so he was just
playing safe and positioned this good
you can wait to play G for like a
thousand blues from now and it'll still
be good
but you do have to worry about black
being able to play G for himself and
preventing your idea so g4 immediately
would have been a very strong
continuation said Queen d4 okay also
fantastic the Queen looks in a lot of
the dark squares and yeah he's got he's
got a lot of good squares for all of his
pieces here again g4 you know very
strong Bishop b1 maybe he's just waiting
for black to make a mistake but black
actually did a really good job of not
doing anything too dramatic or ever you
know radically changing the position I
mean okay this this was a bit of a
mistake to allow this structure what
happened
hopefully this is still the game um but
yeah so he's done a good job not you
know overreacting not you know doing
something you know crazy right you know
but uh he's good at not doing anything
that would drastically changed the
position in White's favor so the
grammarian he's patient come on come on
black do something
Bishop eight again black sort of
considered to move like g4 just to
prevent white from playing it Queen h5
in this position and you want to
sometimes go here mm-hmm
so I guess I'm you know to play here
what do you wanted to get your rooks in
somehow yeah something like that it's
actually it's a very interesting plan
yeah you can use like all of it well
well yeah yeah but yeah maybe somehow if
I can get my other rook over here double
them up and yeah that's interesting and
that is sort of the side of the board
you need to be playing on I wonder if he
would ever sneak in himself that would
have been interesting as well but okay
babe it should be I think g4 though I
guess was just because I never want
white to play here and why should have
played g4 like every move but never gave
it mm-hmm okay so g4 should be played
here you went here in deep anticipation
of darienne's idea okay he's going to
switch the rook over to the Kings side
and so again g4 but Ritchie to indeed
making everything ready you know uh okay
so so g4 very good you know I still has
to break through here it's you know he's
obviously better and pressing and
pressing but black isn't doing anything
overly committal and uh you know he's
still he's still holding in they're
still doing fine so we got this trade
right now what do you guys trade queens
here some people are violently shaking
their head now they're like no way no
way which is probably correct you could
play a move like h5 probably and you can
trade on on my terms
you can move the Queen back you can even
play move like c5
there's a lot of stuff to do I what
would you play Bishop h5 is also a very
very reasonable move and after this
trade and I think white in this position
is just very happy to trade pieces you
know he might even just go trade some
more pieces just because the end game
will always favor white because of his
pawn structure so he's he's very happy
to go into an endgame black did take
which I probably would have tried to
avoid the more pieces that comes off the
easier the endgame is actually going to
be for white to play okay but the bishop
came in and now this looks you know very
reasonable if we just get to install
this bishop somewhere if we get to go
here if we get to go here and here you
know we're looking at a very decent game
but white have this well calculated and
there is a tactic now that did decide
the game does anybody see it just push
the pawn just this one okay and that's
what was played
he took here and yeah the bishop took on
that five and now it's it's looking grim
it's looking grim it's not over though
it's not over yeah there's a paint on
the G file so this happened okay um you
know white still has to has to crash
through but it's getting it's getting
easier in here which is another little
mistake I mean obviously you're worse
and it's not easy to do very much in
this position but again you don't want
to trade when you're you're worse you
have the worst pawn structure the
endgame is going to be worse for you so
you should try to keep as many pieces on
as you can because this King is
obviously going to start marching up the
board have any more Brooks on the board
makes it slightly more dangerous for him
and somehow you have to get some sort of
like fake counter play somehow it
doesn't really exist because you're
you're worse and probably losing you
know but you got to make them got to
make them work this doesn't make the
technical task a little bit easier for
white
and yeah he advances his pawns
now you find you if I think it's
something going but it's a little too
late and ok white white swooped in and
black resigned in this position but I
mean ok for not being a chess player for
very long for having you'll just learned
and you put up such a big struggle
against a grandmaster as a fantastic
sign so yeah I hope you do you do
continue to play and hopefully we went
over some of the Stonewall themes that
can perhaps help you in your future
games you do want to get rid of your bad
bishop keep your good bishop and when
you have you know the worst pond
structure and you're facing a worse
endgame you do want to keep as many
pieces on the board and avoiding trades
but thank you for sending in that that
fantastic submission it was uh you know
one of the better ones I really enjoyed
it I like seeing very few people
actually send in their losses I noticed
several you know everybody wants to see
on the internet this great fantastic
game that I won oh look at me I crushed
somebody 300 points higher rated I'm the
best and I'm happy to show those two
because those often are a lot of fun and
but yeah just thanks for sending in this
game if you like this video hit like
share subscribe and we'll see you guys
next week for some more strategy session
you